well as of monday
word came out that the nfl is taking
over the investigation but chris it's
not as clean as it should be as it
relates to the nfl stepping in
they're still going to let the
investigator previously hired by
washington and by owner dan snyder
to run the investigation i think to have
a truly independent investigation you
have to acknowledge that it was never
independent from the get-go that there
are real issues about the team
hiring selecting paying the person who's
investigating the team let's just reset
hand the files over to the new
investigator and let's go that way so
maybe they're moving in that direction
first step is the nfl is taking over the
investigation what that ultimately means
remains to be seen but they had to do it
it was horrible optics to let washington
run an investigation of itself
especially now the investigation was
directly involving the owner of the team
yeah i i mean this is the proper thing i
mean it's still not all the way proper i
mean it's not you know just like you
just said that's the first thing you
know we're gonna let the person that
washington hired still lead the
investigation you know how far are they
gonna really get mike i'll refer to
something you said in you know on the
article on pro football talk just you
know why would anybody really want to
talk to that person that is accusing
daniel snyder or the washington football
team of any of this when you know wait
daniel snyder hired this person so
anything i say
is going to be construed in a manner
that oh might help out washington and
daniel snyder that's just not a good
look for the nfl and i certainly don't
think it's a good look for the nfl right
now in the circumstances of the world
and where we're at and of course we're
very tough on players and their policies
and anything they do wrong off the field
or might have done wrong and this kind
of just looks like weak like oh hey
you're an owner and oh okay well yeah
we'll do an investigation it just
doesn't look good
a couple of things real quickly first
according to the washington post daniel
snyder has released current and former
employees from non-disclosure agreements
that would
allow them to cooperate with the
investigation now that doesn't mean
presumably they can go tell their
stories on the record to the washington
post or anyone else and i get the
impression because they mention current
and former employees being released from
non-disclosure agreements i get the
impression they sign those agreements on
the way in right that they yeah and
that's the way to do it right when
someone wants a job they'll sign
anything you put in front of them i want
the job on the way out to get somebody
to sign an nda you're going to have to
give them some money and it could be
some signed settlement agreements later
but to get the impression since current
employees had to be released from the
nda they all have an nda they're all
under an obligation to not talk uh but
they can talk to the investigator but
but you know here's the thing chris i
think back to the bounty scandal i think
back to deflategate i think back to the
bullying scandal with the dolphins i
think back to what happened with jerry
richardson and the panthers there's
always a sense when the nfl gets
involved that the nfl is getting
involved in order to drop the hammer
with this one
i feel like the nfl is trying to help
daniel schneider i agree that they're
not truly going in in an unbiased
objective way to gather the facts and if
need be to remove daniel snyder or
otherwise punish him or the team i feel
like they're trying to set this up for
some sort of a soft landing and and
that's just the visceral sense i get
based on the way the nfl's handled this
versus the way the nfl's handled all of
these other situations where it's clear
the nfl is coming after someone yeah i
mean it totally seems like that you know
i don't know if you remember remember
late last week we were you and i were
texting
and i i threw out like maybe the nfl
knows something we don't know here
because i i wonder because that's how it
does look you're right it looks like
they're like oh we don't want anything
to happen here
you know we we want this to work out for
daniel snyder and washington and nothing
be bad you know behind you know door
number three or whatever that is it
certainly seems that way so again i
don't know and as we talked about last
week i certainly think there were some
people that this was a constructed smear
campaign and people are out to get
daniel snyder whether anything is true
or false hey i don't know well time will
tell but uh you know that that's
sometimes i just go back to that and
going maybe the nfl knows something more
than we than we know
let's try this yeah
this is
partially based on what's reported
a little bit based on things i've heard
and i'm going to throw a little
speculation on the tail end of it
what if the nfl is treading lightly here
because this investigation inescapably
will wander into the territory that
daniel snyder has
has uh
entered into on his own with the lawsuit
in india the legal action in virginia
trying to get to the bottom of who is
smearing him and it's become clear he
believes it's one of his minority
partners dwight schar hasn't come out
and said it directly but he's come damn
close to saying it all right
if that's true and if that all comes up
as part of this investigation
if there's any tentacles from shar back
to anyone else with any other team or
with the league office or like this is
if there's any way and this is the
speculation but if there's any way this
all collapses on shar and the league or
anyone else in the league that's in
cahoots with char maybe that's why
they're treading lightly
maybe maybe they know that there's a way
this all falls apart in a way that puts
mud and blood all over the nfl yeah it's
interesting mike i mean
you know that's all speculation we get
it i got you but that would explain why
all of a sudden the league is taking a
hands-off approach not hands-off but but
far closer to hands-off than hands right
like we're in this at le you know hey
public eye look we're in this we're
doing this but they're not really
getting into the the nitty-gritty
details or maybe wanting to find all the
real answers i don't know where this
goes in washington but hopefully it all
gets fixed the right way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports